reporting on hometown hits for years now
and we introduce another hometown hit
tonight john treats joining us in studio
here
a young man's dream becoming a spartan
making a difference on the football
field huh john
that's right chris junior carmoda is the
senior class president at las vegas high
school
he's got a 3.5 gpa and earned more
friends than
you and i can count if that's not enough
this six foot five
250 pound friendly force has accepted a
scholarship to play college football
it's 2020 and junior carmona gave all of
his las vegas high school teammates and
coaches a rare reason to celebrate
the las vegas captain announced he's
going away to san jose state carmona is
a standout tied in
but such a physically advanced and smart
athlete because he plays basketball too
he's going to play offensive tackle for
the spartans
carmona wants to major in journalism and
get his degree but
when the weight room and training table
take over his frame
watch out mountain west conference this
las vegas is going to make
an impact the hours i've spent like
thinking about this decision and
the toll that it's taken on me i'm just
so glad it's over with
and this ranks up there as the most
important this is where i'm gonna be for
the next four years
my life and this just chooses out where
i'm gonna go after this
and so i'm just so glad that they gave
me a chance and all those coaches at
san jose state have been nothing but
amazing for me oh my i felt like
we're in the locker room after a big win
against a big team
just everybody smiles and i couldn't be
any happier myself
and chris he's got a great story this
kid is a first generation american
his parents have been together for 41
years and he's going to go to college
like his parents uh it's a great example
back to you johnny i got to ask you did
you check that guy's birth certificate
because he's a high school
kid that is a teenager yeah really
we're just getting started here on game
on